hello there fans and welcome I said that
with such bitterness yes hello there
fans welcome to Summer s'mores another
installment of Summer Sports and I say I
think I said fans because I think this
is one for the real hardcore fans yeah
because
um I'm not I'm not trying to shoe anyone
else away I invite you to experience
this but uh this is kind of something
special we do around this time of year
and
um it's taken on a life of its own Matt
refresh my memory how did this all get
started in your opinion well the first
year of this podcast we did a special
summer series with Dana Carvey called
Deep dive with Dana Carter yes then the
next year we at this point we had
already had an argument about s'mores
and and Conan and I were absolutely
correct in that they're an overrated
dessert and Sony you did your best to
defend an indefensible situation yeah
that s'mores were something people
actually liked two dry shingles with
some tasteless goo jammed in between
Chase's goo is marshmallow and chocolate
two of the greatest
usually a very inferior grade of
chocolate but anyway the summer series
where we debated that right and then and
that took off uh and guess what the
overwhelming consensus online uh was
that we were correct
online what are you doing I went online
earlier today is not that Abacus
yes you don't read stuff about the show
you it's not like you're looking at
comments I've got my finger on the pulse
he has people for that I have people for
that I have three AI Bots that tell me
what's going on I don't know what to do
with a I also make my scrambled eggs in
the morning oh wait that's that's my
servant Worcestershire
um Matt yeah and then because we called
it summer s'mores we decided let's do
one because we were debating summer
s'mores so much we decided let's let's
do one in your backyard field tested a
field tested yeah so we took a year off
for the pandemic then we did that we
took a year out from the pandemic well
you took a year off I uh did my best to
create a cure I worked very hard with
various scientists it turns out I'm not
a medical professional right right we
could have told you that yeah everybody
could have told I wish someone had I
went and bought a lab coat at a
Halloween store oh and said let me in
here I can fix this kovid you put on
your doctor voice and they still didn't
thank you well that's not my doctor
voice that's my newsman voice and that
was one of the problems can I hear your
doctor I kept throwing to traffic and
weather my doctor voices hmm yeah yeah
hard to believe no one would trust me
yes kovitz yes
I'll need my microscope in my various
implements
so uh we took some time off or you did I
worked hard to save us all I did I think
in my own way yeah and then we went into
your backyard and we had a cookout and
we made some s'mores so that we could
really test whether or not we liked them
or not I thought again these were
perfectly normal s'mores made the way
most people make s'mores my opinion did
not change I didn't find them to be
tasty at all what about you no my if
anything it was reinforced and just it
was decisive yeah decisive it was just
awful Sona did you like the s'mores we
had loved them I could have had 40.
right can I just say can I just say one
thing this disqualifies you a little bit
which is after you ate the last s'more I
heard you saying Yum Yum Yum this is
good too and I looked over and you were
chewing on a a rock that you had found
at the base of an oak tree yeah and you
also had a bowl of our garden mulch yeah
at one point you said this is also good
and then you said yummy yummy yummy what
good pasta you were eating a garden hose
I didn't know you two were like
it's a good thing he had that glue trap
because
best way to catch a rat it's with a glue
trap uh anyway I hate this so far well
listen it's gonna get a lot better but
then for you much worse okay so we did
that last and and people seem to really
enjoy that we were really outside and we
loved it and then we were thinking what
do we do this summer since the s'mores
debate's been settled yeah they didn't
need to cover that we didn't need to
cover that anymore but let's say we
wanted to move on from we do move we did
we we did yeah we did okay we did want
to move on from s'mores right good Sona
speech Champion yeah and you've moved on
from the English language yeah you moved
on from enunciating but anyway uh we
decided let's let's try something a
little different this year and the first
decision we made which I think is going
to work out we haven't done it yet but
what we're going to do is we have this
very nice facility here in the Larchmont
area of Los Angeles uh where we do our
podcasting there's editing facilities
it's a great place to hang guests that
come on the show where they like to be
here and we have an uh an outdoor area
it's quite lovely and so we thought what
if we do it sheer Outdoors at night and
record it over several sessions and
maybe switch it up a little bit but try
and recapture some of that magic from
last summer so um what do you think Matt
do you think this is going to be a good
idea I think it's a great idea that
um the outdoor deck is just literally
right outside this door it's beautiful
it's when you say this store of course
this is an audio medium let me tell the
people that he's gesturing to a tour
right here in the studio
this door imply that there is a door
yeah there are hinges and it opens and
there is a knob
when you walk through it and it enters
you enter another area familiar with
what a door is oh I'm quite familiar
with what a door is yes and I'll be
escorting you through one in about five
minutes it goes
there's a door in the studio that goes
right to this very nice just said that
in this studio yes can I ask will Matt
be making drinks this time because last
year everyone got a well everyone minus
Conan I was I was I showed a lot of
moderation last year full tea totally
well but I I'm a professional I am I'm a
professional and uh last year last year
Matt what did you make last year it was
amazing I made uh the chilled Chum yeah
and tell us what it was it it was
bourbon pomegranate juice ginger beer I
think maybe a little lemon and then as
you put it pulverized Mouse Hearts but
the rest modeled straight there was
little chunks of what looked like
shredded mice hearts in there but
um I don't care what it was it was
delicious yeah very good I now here's
what I'm gonna say I don't go too crazy
so I took it slow
um you got yourself I would say you got
yourself into a happy place but you
weren't out of control good and tight
Sona I'm gonna say this you don't even
have to have that much no and you get
wasted and I remember this from the
years and years of us touring doing
shows in other cities traveling around
if we ever hit a bar you would have one
glass of white wine that was it and
you'd be making out with a parking meter
okay making out with a parking no I
wouldn't I'm talking about a very good
looking Park oh okay then yeah
uh yeah and my tolerance is though it's
gotten even lower because I don't drink
that often now I I partake in uh you
know kind of kind of kind of buy can I
buy weed pot
Jazz cigarettes weed pot wheat pot
so uh so that's so your tolerance is
even lower so we just have to watch it
this year yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna be much more uh responsible than I
was last year possibly yeah let's just
see what happens I will I'm gonna my I'm
gonna uh
what's the word moderate you don't even
know the word it's not in your
dictionary it's myself have you done
some pre-gaming no no I wish I I did